[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich finde, es ist mal wieder Zeit für eine Motivtorte.
Ich glaube, die letzte große Motivtorte war tatsächlich
die Harry-Potter-Torte.
Und jetzt für den Sommer habe ich mir gedacht:
"Was mache ich denn da?"
Im Sommer backe ich eigentlich nicht so gerne Motivtorten.
Denn bei uns gibt es da irgendwie keinen Anlass.
Ich habe zwar im August Geburtstag, aber
ich backe mir ja nicht selber eine Motivtorte.
Und die Kinder haben alle im Winter und Murat im Herbst.
Also gibt es heute trotzdem einfach außerhalb der Reihe
mal eine Motivtorte.
Ich habe was gesehen und zwar Kawaii.
Das heißt auf Japanisch süß.
Und es gibt auch diese speziellen Zeichnungen.
Samira zeichnet das auch immer ganz gerne.
Also so eine Ananas, die süß aussieht,
oder eine Wassermelone mit so kleinen Augen dran.
Und das ist irgendwie so eine ganz eigene Kunst.
Und ich dachte mir, ich nehme das jetzt als Inspiration
und backe eine Kawaii-Motivtorte.
Also Motiv habe ich mir eine
Ananas ausgesucht!
Diese Ananas, die backe ich jetzt mit Augen dran.
Und ich glaube, das ist dann eine ziemlich süße Motivtorte,
die man zum Geburtstag verschenken kann
oder auch einfach mal,
wenn man eine Sommer-Hawaii-Party schmeißt,
vielleicht sogar eine Poolparty, wenn man einen Pool hat,
und dann kann man diese Motivtorte backen.
So stelle ich es mir zumindest mal vor.
Oder einfach so, wenn man Lust darauf hat
und weil man es süß findet.
Also die Ananas stelle ich jetzt hier hin.
Denn die sieht süß aus.
Ja.
Man sieht sie nicht.
Die Ananas stelle ich jetzt hier rein.
Ich lege sie rein.
So.
Perfekt!
Ja.
Hier, Hawaii, Kawaii.
Ich glaube...
Ich weiß nicht, woher der Name kommt.
Jedenfalls backe ich hier jetzt.
Ich habe eine Umfrage gemacht,
ob ihr Ananas und Kokos mögt, also so Piña Colada.
Denn jetzt werde ich eine Piña-Colada-Torte backen.
Wenn ihr sagt, "Ich bin da nicht so der Fan davon",
dann macht doch einfach einen Schokoboden zum Beispiel,
eine Schokocreme.
Da gibt es ja schon bereits ganz viele Rezepte
auf meinem Kanal.
Dann könnt ihr die Torte trotzdem backen
aber mit anderem Inhalt.
Ich brauche für den Teig
sechs Eier,
– die sind bereits zimmerwarm –
eine Prise Salz,
300 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 300 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch,
450 Gramm Mehl,
200 Gramm Kokosraspeln
und ein Päckchen Backpulver,
das sind drei Teelöffel.
Ich nehme jetzt erst die Eier.
Die kommen in die Rührschüssel
gemeinsam mit dem Zucker und Salz
und Vanilleextrakt.
Es neigt sich dem Ende zu.
[Musik]
Und dann verrührt ihr die Masse
für etwa fünf bis sieben Minuten,
bis sie schön weißcremig ist.
[Musik]
Guckt euch das an!
So schön cremig gerührt!
Hier habe ich jetzt schon zwei Backringe
auf 18 cm Durchmesser eingestellt
und mit Backpapier eingeschlagen.
Denn das ist ein sehr flüssiger Teig.
Und 18 cm deswegen, weil die Torte schön hoch werden soll.
Und
– was wollte ich noch?
Und zwei Ringe deswegen, weil einfach das viel Masse ist
und ich habe eine kürzere Backzeit
und er backt eben auch gleichmäßiger.
Daher die zwei Ringe.
Jetzt könnt ihr die zwei Flüssigkeiten hier dazu geben,
Öl und Buttermilch.
Statt Buttermilch könnt ihr auch,
wenn jetzt keine Kinder mitessen
und ihr nichts dagegen habt,
könnt ihr auch zum Beispiel Batida de Côco dazu geben,
also so ein bisschen Kokoslikör.
Zack!
Buttermilch macht den Teig einfach so megamegasaftig!
Die Zutaten rühre ich kurz ein.
Und dann kommen schon die trockenen dazu.
Und, wenn ihr den Kokosgeschmack verstärken wollt,
könnt ihr die Kokosraspeln auch
in einer Pfanne ein bisschen rösten.
Ich lasse sie jetzt allerdings so.
Denn so schmeckt es auch schon sehr gut.
So hat man einfach noch mal so ein Röstaroma mit drin.
Mehl und Backpulver.
Und jetzt nur noch so lange verrühren,
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat.
[Musik]
Der Teig sieht einfach so gut aus!
Und jetzt teile ich den hier auf
und fülle ihn ein.
[Musik]
Jetzt dürft ihr den Teig gern
so ein bisschen am Rand hochstreichen.
So geht er noch gleichmäßiger auf.
Und dann wird er schon gebacken.
>> JOSH: Ich filme gerade auch die Ananas im Hintergrund.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
Guckt mal, wie perfekt der Kuchen jetzt einfach aussieht!
Ich habe die Stäbchenprobe gemacht.
Das bedeutet,
ihr nehmt einen Zahnstocher,
stecht in die Mitte des Teiges,
also am Backofen
– des Kuchens, nicht des Teiges.
Denn jetzt ist es kein Teig mehr.
Und, wenn dann nichts mehr daran kleben bleibt,
ist er fertig.
Da war jetzt noch ein Krümel dran.
Aber das war okay.
Es war nichts Feuchtes mehr dran.
So lasse ich den jetzt abkühlen
und werde in der Zwischenzeit mich schon mal um die
Ananas kümmern!
Mir ist nämlich gerade eingefallen:
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt machen werde?
Ein Ananas-Curd.
So wie Lemon Curd
Ananas-Curd.
Mmh!
Und hier lege ich einfach ein Tuch drauf.
Dann kann es schön abkühlen.
Und nach dem Abkühlen
kommt es noch mal in den Kühlschrank.
Denn kühlschrankkalter Kuchen
lässt sich einfach viel besser schneiden.
Für das Ananas-Curd nehme ich jetzt
eine Ananas,
zwei Eier.
Hier habe ich noch etwas Zucker,
Stärke und Butter.
Die genauen Mengen schreibe ich euch dann einfach
in die App beziehungsweise in den Blog.
Denn ich weiß noch nicht, ob sie passen.
Ich probiere es einfach aus.
Eine Ananas erkennt...
Also die Reife der Ananas erkennt ihr übrigens daran,
ihr geht zum Supermarkt oder zum Wochenmarkt
– meistens sind sie ja schon essreif
und werden auch reif angeboten.
Aber ihr könnt mal schauen,
denn manche brauchen einfach noch mal ein, zwei Tage.
Und dann nehmt ihr hier oben diese Blätter
und, wenn die sich leicht lösen lassen,
dann ist die Ananas reif.
Also gerade so die in der Mitte.
Ich will jetzt nicht alle rausziehen,
weil ich die Ananas so schön finde.
Vielleicht brauchen wir die später
für das Foto noch.
Und daran erkennt ihr es.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt eine recht kleine.
Und ich nehme jetzt hier
den Deckel weg.
Und jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder
mit dem Messer einfach schälen
oder ihr nehmt einen Ananasschneider,
was ich ganz praktisch finde
vor allem, weil bei uns die Ela total gerne Ananas isst.
Dann kann man das nämlich hier so reindrehen.
Und entweder hört ihr dann früher auf zu drehen
und könnt dann das noch als Gefäß benutzen.
Ich glaube, das mache ich jetzt.
Denn da gieße ich dann einfach Wasser rein
und dann kann die Ela mit einem Strohhalm daraus trinken.
So.
Ihr seht, jetzt ist da auch noch ein bisschen Ananas drin.
Aber, wie gesagt, das passt.
Und die Mitte hier, die könnt ihr auch nehmen.
Die schneide ich jetzt mit einem Messer raus.
Denn da stecken auch ganz, ganz viele Vitamine drin.
Die meisten essen es nur nicht,
weil der Strunk einfach,
ja, so ein bisschen holzig auch ist von der Textur her.
Aber, wie gesagt, hier im Ananas-Curd
macht mir das gar nichts oder in einem Smoothie.
So.
Wie gesagt, das lasse ich jetzt für die Ela
und die Samira.
Zerkleinern muss ich es jetzt gar nicht,
denn ich werde es direkt pürieren.
Ich wiege es mir jetzt nur kurz ab.
Dann kann ich euch direkt
die Ananasmenge perfekt aufschreiben.
Hier habe ich noch was übrig
vom letzten Mal.
Ich gebe jetzt hier einfach noch die Eier mit rein.
Denn dann muss ich nichts klümpchenfrei verrühren,
sondern kann direkt
alles so vermischen.
Außer die Butter, die kommt zum Schluss dazu.
[Musik]
Und jetzt alles fein pürieren.
Strom!
Strom braucht er.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt die Mischung in einen Topf.
Und dann könnt ihr sie bei mittelhoher Hitze
unter ständigem Rühren einmal kurz aufkochen lassen.
Und ein Lemon Curd ist auch superlecker!
Und das ist zum einen eine richtig leckere Tortenfüllung
oder ihr könnt damit auch Quark verrühren
oder das Ganze wie so eine Art Marmelade
auf Brot genießen.
Also echt megalecker!
Das mache ich total gerne!
Hätte ich etwa einen größeren Topf nehmen sollen?
>> JOSH: Ich denke, es reicht.
>> SALLY: Nehmt einen größeren Topf bitte.
Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Aber ich lerne nicht daraus.
Egal.
Waghäusel ist stabil, Junge!
Arbeitsamt hat Geld auf Konto gewiesen, ey, hey!
Lohn ist da!
>> JOSH: Sehr gut! Der ultimative Karaokesong.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Wer kennt Teddy?
Bitte stellt mich Teddy vor!
Ich will mit Teddy backen!
Ja.
Aber dann muss er einmal für mich
den Freddie Mercury machen!
Ich liebe das Video!
Sogar Samira und Ela feiern ihn.
Teddy, bitte komm und backe mit mir!
Ich backe dir auch was
und koche was!
Bis das hier warm wird,
kann ich auch schon mal den Mixer reinigen.
Und zwar reinige ich so einen Blender immer:
Etwas Spülmittel rein,
bei mir jetzt noch einen Spritzer Essig,
da ich Eier noch drin hatte,
und Wasser und dann mixen.
Und dann wird der Blender schon von alleine sauber.
Vergesst aber nicht zu rühren!
Habe ich gestern den Essig wieder leer gemacht.
Natürlich!
Ich bin echt also...
Ich glaube, ich muss mal meine Nase irgendwie...
Ich rieche einfach dieses Ei.
Ich kann das nicht.
Und dann muss ich immer Essig
beziehungsweise Essigessenz benutzen,
um den Geruch zu neutralisieren.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Masse aufgekocht
– guckt mal – und auch eingedickt.
Perfekt!
Und jetzt
– normalerweise würde ich sie
noch durch ein Sieb streichen.
Aber ich muss sagen...
Ups!
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe es ja jetzt sowieso püriert.
Daher streiche ich es jetzt nicht mehr durch.
Aber, wenn ihr die Ananas nicht so ganz fein bekommt
und die Eier danach erst dazu gebt mit der Stärke,
auf jeden Fall durchsieben,
damit eben keine Klümpchen entstehen. Okay?
Jetzt hier umfüllen, damit es eben auch schnell abkühlen kann.
Wir müssen die jetzt auch probieren, Josh.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich habe das zum ersten Mal gemacht.
>> JOSH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Nie mit Ananas?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> JOSH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Ich kannte immer nur so Lemon Curd,
Lemon Curd.
Jetzt dachte ich:
"Wie kriege ich die Ananasfüllung in die Torte?
Mache ich eine Fruchteinlage?"
Und irgendwie kam so Ananas-Curd.
Und jetzt die kalte Butter dazu.
Dadurch kühlt das Ganze natürlich auch noch mal schnell ab.
Und dann füllt ihr es am besten im Marmeladengläser ab.
Und durch das Abkühlen wird es natürlich
auch von der Konsistenz her fester.
Es ist jetzt nicht so lange haltbar wie Marmelade
zum einen, weil ich wenig, wirklich wenig Zucker drin habe,
und zum anderen natürlich auch wegen den Eiern
und der Butter.
Also so eine Woche im Kühlschrank
geht auf jeden Fall.
Aber länger solltet ihr es nicht aufbewahren.
Okay, ich hole mal kurz zwei Löffel.
Und ich bin Fan davon, dass die Füllung jetzt hoffentlich nicht
zu süß ist,
damit es die Torte ausgleicht geschmacklich.
Vorsicht, heiß!
Geht.
Gut!
>> JOSH: Mega!
>> SALLY: Und durch das Erhitzen
passiert auch Folgendes.
Wenn ihr jetzt Ananas mit Joghurt vermischt,
dann wird es bitter.
Also auch Ananas im Müsli zum Beispiel wird bitter
oder Smoothie mit Ananas und Milch wird bitter,
weil einfach Ananas ein Enzym hat,
was eben mit Milch oder mit Milchprodukten reagiert
und dann wird dieser bittere Geschmack hervorgerufen.
Aber durch das Erhitzen geht das kaputt.
Und jetzt kann ich diese Torte ganz, wie ich möchte,
zum Beispiel auch mit Quark vermischen,
also diese Masse.
Und dann habt ihr das eben nicht mehr.
Also erhitzen und dann geht es kaputt.
Das ist auch bei Kiwi so
oder bei Ananas aus der Dose.
Nur so als Fakt
zwischendurch.
>> JOSH: Du musst dich nicht rechtfertigen.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß.
So. Ich fülle das jetzt um
und dann darf es abkühlen
und dann kümmere ich mich eigentlich schon um die Creme.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich die Zutaten für die Buttercreme.
Ich mache jetzt eine Swiss Meringue Buttercream.
Ihr könnt auch eine italienische Buttercreme machen
oder eine französische Buttercreme.
Ich mache das jetzt hier als Eiweißresteverwertung,
weil ich einfach noch ganz viel übrig hatte.
Ich verwende dafür
Eiweiß,
Zucker,
Salz.
Hier habe ich noch etwas Kokoscreme,
Butter
und Puderzucker.
Bei der Kokoscreme habe ich es einfach so gemacht,
ich habe eine Dose Kokosmilch verwendet,
nicht geschüttelt.
Denn da setzt sich ja dieser fettige Bestandteil
– also das ist ja eine 60%ige Kokosmilch –
setzt sich dann oben ab.
Und dann dürft ihr nicht schütteln
und schöpft das einfach weg.
Und so bekommt ihr in diese Buttercreme
einfach noch Kokosgeschmack mit rein.
Mache ich jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Ich teste es jetzt einfach.
Wichtig ist jetzt bei der Buttercreme nur,
dass das Eiweiß mit dem Salz und Zucker
verrührt und erwärmt wird.
Das könnt ihr entweder
über einem warmen Wasserbad machen,
also eben ein Topf mit Wasser,
darüber eine Schüssel
und dann wirklich zehn Minuten lang
über dem kochenden Wasserbad erwärmen,
oder ihr nehmt eine Küchenmaschine,
stellt die auf 70°C ein und erwärmt es dort für zehn Minuten.
So mache ich es jetzt, weil es schneller und einfacher geht.
[Musik]
Hier also einfach die Zutaten reingeben.
Dann wähle ich hier 70°C
und lasse auf etwa Stufe 3 bis 4 rühren.
Bei 60°C schaltet sich die Maschine automatisch ab.
Das ist so eine Sicherheitsfunktion.
Und dann drücke ich hier einfach auf den Knopf,
damit die Maschine weiß, da ist jemand da.
Und dann schlägt sie eben auch wieder auf Stufe 4 weiter.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach hier draufdrücken
und dann kommt die Geschwindigkeit wieder zurück.
Die Masse erwärmt jetzt auf 70°C.
Und wenn sie dann 70°C warm ist,
ab dann zähle ich die zehn Minuten.
Und dann schalte ich aber die Hitze ab.
Das heißt, das ist auch der Moment,
an dem ihr praktisch
das Eiweiß vom Wasserbad runternehmt.
Und dann muss es kalt gerührt werden.
Das dauert dann auch noch mal so etwa
10, 15 bis 20 Minuten
je nach Außentemperatur.
Und solange hole ich Fondant.
Denn wir können gleich schon eine Deko herstellen.
Während die Eiweißmasse jetzt noch kalt wird,
kann ich jetzt schon mal die Butter
gemeinsam mit der Kokoscreme und dem Puderzucker
richtig schön weißcremig rühren.
Das dauert so etwa fünf bis sechs Minuten.
[Musik]
Wenn die Eiweißmasse dann wieder kalt gerührt ist
und die Buttermasse weich gerührt ist,
werden die beiden Komponenten verbunden.
[Musik]
Und diese Konsistenz bekommt ihr wirklich nur hin,
wenn das Eiweiß schon wieder kalt gerührt ist
und die Butter wirklich schön zimmerwarm war,
flauschig, fluffig und schaumig gerührt wurde.
Und jetzt habt ihr einfach die perfekte Buttercreme.
It's like heaven!
[Musik]
Tortenboden ist stabil, Junge!
Und dann werden die Böden
mit einer Tortensäge durchgeschnitten.
So dünn, wie ihr sie haben möchtet.
[Musik]
Ach, das passt perfekt!
Ich habe sie gedrittelt.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich noch
diesen Fondantstrunk machen.
Aber ich kam noch nicht dazu.
Denn ich habe mich dazu entschlossen,
zwischendrin noch Pizza zu machen,
damit wir was zu essen haben.
Und dann muss halt der Strunk jetzt ein bisschen warten.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Torte füllen.
Ich fülle sie jetzt
und stapel sie erst mal auf so einem Ganaching Board.
Dann kann ich sie nämlich auch wunderbar wegheben.
Damit es darauf jetzt nicht so sehr rutscht,
einfach zum Befestigen
etwas Buttercreme.
Dann den ersten Boden drauf setzen.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könntet ihr die Böden
jetzt auch gern noch mal mit Batida de Côco tränken.
Aber sie sind auch so schon supersaftig!
Da gebe ich jetzt mein Ananas-Curd drauf.
Wenn ihr das ein bisschen fester haben wollt,
gebt ihr einfach ein bisschen mehr Butter dazu.
Denn die Butter, die bindet das Ganze ja auch
und macht es dann eben so streichfähig cremig.
Aber ich finde es so jetzt
von der Konsistenz her echt gut.
Ich streiche jetzt hier eine dünne Schicht eher drauf
und darüber eine dünne Schicht Buttercreme.
Ich muss jetzt nur gucken, dass die nicht rutscht.
Theoretisch könnt ihr auch beides verbinden.
Dann kommt der nächste Boden drauf.
Und so füllt ihr jetzt die gesamte Torte.
[Musik]
Höhe passt.
Und jetzt mache ich es so,
ich drehe es um
und setze noch den anderen Deckel unten dran.
Dann habe ich schon mal die zwei Rundungen.
Yes!
Das sah ein bisschen wackelig aus, ich weiß.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen Angst, weil sie noch so...
Wisst ihr was?
Ich kühle sie erst und dann setze ich den Boden dran.
Denn
denn die Creme muss erst einmal fest werden.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Torte gekühlt.
Ich habe sie übrigens noch
mit dem Tortenring einfach ein bisschen stabilisiert.
Vor allem trocknet sie dann auch nicht aus.
Also ich lasse Torten eigentlich nie
unabgedeckt im Kühlschrank,
außer sie haben schon eine Fondantschicht.
Jetzt kann ich die Torte auf den Kopf drehen.
Yes!
Da funktioniert es auch.
Ha, witzig!
Da steht "Sally" in Spiegelschrift.
Und hier mache ich es jetzt so,
damit die Optik später auch passt,
denn jetzt ist der Kuchen ja umgedreht,
jetzt kommt hier
die Kokosbuttercreme,
weil der kleine Monk in mir sagt:
"Jetzt kannst du es nicht andersrum machen."
Es muss die gleiche Optik haben.
Und dann
nehme ich die Creme,
die Ananascreme,
und die kommt hierhin.
Ta-daa!
Hervorragend!
Und zack!
Und jetzt ist der Tag leider schon zu sehr fortgeschritten.
Ich hätte heute noch gerne weitergemacht,
aber wir haben heute so viel zwischenrein gemacht,
dass es jetzt schon wieder 18:30 Uhr wurde.
Tja.
Deswegen packe ich die Torte jetzt ein
und mache morgen weiter.
Ist sicherer für uns alle.
Und die restliche Buttercreme,
die kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Die nehme ich morgen dann kurz vorher raus.
Dann kann ich sie noch mal verrühren
und dann ist sie auch wieder geschmeidig.
Heute ist der nächste Tag.
Man sieht es, gell?
Man sieht es, oder?
Ich bin einen Tag älter geworden.
Ihr aber auch!
Josh, du aber auch!
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber wir haben uns alle jung gehalten.
>> JOSH: Gut.
>> SALLY: Jedenfalls ist die Torte noch in der Kühlung.
Damit mache ich gleich weiter.
Ich möchte jetzt aber zuerst einmal
den Strunk der Ananas machen.
Ich hoffe, das heißt auch Strunk.
Ich denke schon.
Dafür verwende ich
grünen Fondant.
Das ist eine Zuckerüberzugsmasse, die man eben
ganz gerne zum Dekorieren von Torten verwendet.
Und die ist aber schön weich.
Das heißt, wenn ihr diese über die Torte legt,
so wie ich es auch später machen werde
mit dem gelben Fondant,
dann bleibt sie weich.
Und ist ja auch gut so,
denn man möchte die Torte anschneiden und auch essen.
Dann gibt es hier noch Blütenpaste.
Und das ist die Paste, die bei Luft austrocknet.
Das heißt, wenn ihr Blüten modelliert oder Figuren
oder so wie ich jetzt den Strunk,
der ja da oben auch schön stehen soll,
dann verwendet ihr Blütenpaste.
Und wenn ihr diese beiden zusammenmischt,
entsteht Modelliermasse.
Wenn ihr keine Blütenpaste habt,
könnt ihr auch Cellulosepulver nehmen.
Also CMC nennt sich das dann.
Und dann gebt ihr einfach pro 200, 250 Gramm Fondant
ungefähr einen Teelöffel dazu.
Und das bewirkt dann eben auch,
dass die Masse schön aushärtet.
Also so viel zur Theorie.
Denn, wenn ihr jetzt nur den Fondant nehmt
und den Strunk macht,
dann biegen sich die Blätter.
Also die bleiben nicht so,
sondern machen immer wuh.
Und das wäre schade.
Also das jetzt gut zusammenkneten.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Ich glaube, ich färbe es dann noch ein bisschen nach.
Denn jetzt habe ich eher so so ein Pastellgrün.
Aber ich will sowieso zwei, drei Farben haben.
Daher hole ich mir ganz kurz grüne Farbpaste.
Also ich nehme noch ein bisschen Gelb
und etwas Grün.
Und ihr könnt eure Hände immer gerne mit Kokosfett
ein bisschen einfetten.
Dann ist das Kneten nämlich einfacher.
Alles, was ihr nicht verwendet,
einfach schön luftdicht verpacken,
damit es nicht austrocknet.
Und wenn ihr dann eure Wunschfarbe habt
– also immer berücksichtigen,
es wird immer noch ein bisschen dunkler,
wenn es dann eben wieder kalt wird.
Durch das Kneten wird es einfach ein bisschen heller
und dann eben wieder dunkler beim Aushärten.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt mit Bäckerstärke die Masse ausrollen.
Bäckerstärke ist eine Stärke aus Kartoffeln
und die klebt nicht.
Und ihr seht auch ganz schön,
sie ist so ganz fein
und man kann sie später eben schön wieder wegpudern.
[Musik]
Allzu dünn rolle ich das jetzt hier nicht aus.
Denn
es kommt noch Struktur rein.
Und guckt, die Bäckerstärke,
die bekommt ihr ganz einfach wieder weg.
Das klappt mit Puderzucker und mit Speisestärke nicht.
Daher rate ich euch, wirklich Bäckerstärke
zum Ausrollen zu benutzen.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr entweder solche Ausstecher
– die haben eigentlich eine schöne Form,
erinnert auch wirklich an dieses Ananasblatt oben –
oder ihr nehmt ein Marzipanmesser,
also ein stumpfes Messer,
und könnt euch einfach hier diese Form ausschneiden.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach mal.
Die sind schon recht klein.
Aber ich brauche ja kleine und große.
Vielleicht schneide ich ein paar noch händisch dann aus.
Ihr könnt sogar
das hier noch so eindrücken.
Aber ich mache gleich noch Struktur rein auf jeden Fall.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Jetzt habe ich große und kleine Blätter
und schneide jetzt hier einfach noch welche
mithilfe des Blatts aus.
Zack!
Und
zack!
Und jetzt könnt ihr die Blätter noch strukturieren.
Zum Beispiel mit so einem stumpfen Werkzeug
einfach so ein paar Streifen reinziehen,
dass das Ganze einfach lebendiger wird.
Immer so in die eine Richtung,
also zur Spitze hin.
So.
Und dann
werde ich, glaube ich, die Blätter nach oben hin
so ein bisschen ausdünnen.
Ja.
Das sieht gut aus.
Nach oben hin ausdünnen.
Dann überlege ich.
Ich gucke die ganze Zeit die Ananas an.
Dann müssen sie sich so biegen.
Ich glaube, dann lege ich sie einfach
ein bisschen über den Ausrollstab
und lasse sie so ein bisschen antrocknen.
Ja, das ist gut.
[Musik]
Ich habe die Blätter von der Vorder- und Rückseite strukturiert,
damit man eben von beiden Seiten die Struktur hat.
Und jetzt fange ich an, diesen Strunk zu formen.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal die großen Blätter.
Ich habe mir die auch so ein bisschen sortiert.
Dann werden sie in der Mitte,
ja, eigentlich fast so zusammengeknickt.
Da kommt etwas essbarer Kleber rein,
aber nur hier unten.
Und ich nehme jetzt einfach
das zum Stabilisieren.
Also dann versuche ich, die jetzt auch so halb zu überlappen.
Also das in der Mitte lasse ich so.
Und dann,
glaube ich,
– doch, das wird ganz cool –
mache ich das so
und dann setze ich da wieder so das halbe dran.
Das ist schon mal das Innenleben.
Und
es ist noch zu weich.
Ich glaube, ich muss sie antrocknen lassen.
Ja.
Ja, bei den kleinen klappt es gut.
Die stehen auch.
Aber die großen, die muss man schon
ein bisschen antrocknen lassen.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich lasse sie noch antrocknen.
Und dann kleben wir sie zusammen.
Aber die kleinen, die biege ich schon mal so ein bisschen hin.
Und die großen, die lege ich mir auch so irgendwo drüber
mit diesem Knick unten
und der Biegung hier oben nach außen.
Und wenn sie dann ein bisschen angetrocknet sind,
dann lassen sie sich auch kleben.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt noch
ein Stück Blütenpaste einfach ausgerollt.
Ich steche jetzt einfach noch ein paar Blüten aus.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich sie später benutze,
aber ich glaube, es könnte ganz süß aussehen.
Und damit die sich jetzt schön formen
– also normalerweise würde ich sie jetzt
noch mit einem Ball-Tool ausdünnen,
dass sie so ein bisschen realistischer aussehen.
Aber ich finde, dieses Kawaii, dieser Kawaii-Style
lebt ja davon, dass es so comicmäßig aussieht.
Und jetzt lege ich das hier einfach in so Eierschalen rein.
Die wurden mal,
ich glaube, mit meinem Kühlschrank mitgeliefert
und ich lege da meine Eier nie rein.
Ah nee, das sind Eiswürfelbehälter!
Genau. Weil das hat so einen Deckel.
Und ich mache darin aber keine Eiswürfel.
Also benutze ich es dafür.
Und dann haben sie eine schöne Rundung.
Also, wenn ihr mit einem Ball-Tool hier in der Mitte
diese Rundungen einfach noch so ein bisschen vertieft,
dann habt ihr so in sich gewellte Blätter.
Also gar nicht so den Rand ausdünnen,
sondern einfach die Blätter in sich wellen.
[Musik]
Blumen kann man nie genug haben!
Und dann lasse ich die Blüten einfach trocknen.
Die werden später noch
schön bepudert
mit etwas Lebensmittelfarbe.
Und dann kann ich eigentlich schon
mit der Torte weitermachen.
[Musik]
Weiter geht es mit der Torte!
Sie hat ja im Prinzip fast schon die perfekte Form.
Ich denke,
unten kann ich noch ein bisschen eine Rundung reinschneiden.
So,
dass sie unten eben nicht so flach runtergeht,
sondern leicht abgerundet.
Also einfach so ein kleines Messer ansetzen,
hier unten diese Ecke wegnehmen.
Ein kleiner Schritt für mich,
aber ein großer für die Optik des Kuchens,
Oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das war jetzt wirklich ein minimaler Schritt,
aber der macht das dann aus.
Das ist so das Detail.
Ja.
Ich kann ja mal gucken.
Ich streiche es jetzt erst mal ein.
Und dann schaue ich einfach,
ob ich hier
die Form so lasse oder noch mal nachschneide.
Ich nehme jetzt hier ein bisschen von der Buttercreme.
Und ihr könnt die Torte jetzt
entweder komplett mit der Buttercreme einstreichen,
denn die ist ja fondanttauglich.
Also da muss man einfach darauf achten,
dass der Fondant nicht in Berührung
mit Sahnecreme zum Beispiel kommt.
Oder die deutsche Buttercreme mit Pudding,
die funktioniert auch nicht.
Es ist einfach zu viel Flüssigkeit und Feuchtigkeit drin.
Diese Buttercreme funktioniert oder auch die französische
oder auch Ganache.
Und ich gucke mal.
Heute wird es nämlich ein sehr warmer Tag.
Und da finde ich es oftmals einfach besser,
wenn außen noch eine Schicht Ganache darum ist.
Die schmilzt nämlich nicht so schnell wie Butter.
Und dann ist das Verarbeiten immer einfacher.
[Musik]
Dann habe ich jetzt hier schon mal die erste Schicht.
Die bindet jetzt einfach diese Kuchenkrümel,
dass da nichts mehr krümelt
und ich später eine glatte Oberfläche habe
beziehungsweise einen Untergrund für den Fondant.
Die Torte stelle ich jetzt noch mal in den Kühlschrank
für etwa 10 bis 20 Minuten,
kann in der Zwischenzeit aufräumen,
vielleicht sogar schon den Strunk weitermachen.
Und ich werde aber später wirklich
noch ein bisschen Ganache nehmen.
Ich habe noch weiße Ganache eingefroren.
Die taue ich ganz kurz auf.
Ansonsten könnt ihr eine weiße Ganache selbst herstellen.
Da gibt es bereits ein Grundrezept bei mir.
[Musik]
Schaut mal. Jetzt sind die Blätter schön angetrocknet.
Nehmt euch wirklich auch die Zeit.
Denn ich habe meine jetzt auch noch mal frisch gemacht.
Und jetzt kann ich sie zusammenkleben.
Die großen nach innen.
Dann wieder Kleber auf eine Seite
und immer die eine Hälfte an die andere drankleben.
Und dann schließt sich so der innere Kreis.
[Musik]
Und nach außen hin werden dann die Blätter immer kleiner.
Aber oben hänge ich noch auch ein paar kleine rein.
Hm.
Denn die wachsen ja so.
Keine Ahnung, wie die Ananas das macht,
aber sie wächst.
Sie wächst einfach.
Und einfach beim Kleben darauf achten,
dass die Blätter so ein bisschen
überlappen.
Aber ich glaube, ich muss den inneren Kreis
jetzt erst mal stabil kleben.
Stabil, Junge!
Wuhu!
Murats Teeglas
ist das perfekte Ananasstrunkglas.
Ja.
Ich lasse das jetzt richtig gut trocknen.
Diese Blätter, da macht es ja nichts,
wenn die komplett durchtrocknen.
Die kann ich später einfach noch ankleben.
Passt gut.
Aber so der innere Part, der muss jetzt schon
gut trocknen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr die Blätter euch noch so
hinlegen, wie ihr sie braucht,
und lasst das jetzt stehen.
[Musik]
Ja, so geht es.
So ist sie gut.
Und, wie gesagt, habe ich hier
meine Ganache einfach aufgetaut
in einem Topf bei
sehr niedriger Hitze.
Und ich nehme sie jetzt erst einmal so weich, wie sie ist,
damit ich hier auch einmal eine Basis habe.
Das erinnert mich gerade richtig ans Töpfern.
Und ich würde so gerne mal töpfern!
Habt ihr eine Töpferwerkstatt?
Also kennt ihr vielleicht jemanden
aus dem Kreis Karlsruhe, Mannheim oder Heidelberg?
Dann meldet euch!
Denn ich habe was gefunden,
aber da war früher eine und jetzt töpfern sie...
Also da gibt es halt keine Kurse mehr,
sondern die töpfern nur noch auf Anfrage, glaube ich.
Ich würde so gern mal töpfern!
Okay.
Also die Ganache wird jetzt hier fest.
Ich stelle die Torte noch mal kühl.
Diese Ganache stelle ich auch ganz kurz kühl,
damit sie so ein bisschen streichfähiger wird.
Und dann werde ich die Torte einfach einmal komplett glätten
und nehme mir dazu auch eine Teigkarte,
damit auch der Rand schön flach wird.
Sobald die Ganache die perfekte Konsistenz erreicht hat,
könnt ihr mit so einer flexiblen Teigkarte
wirklich richtig schön die Oberfläche glätten
in nur ganz wenigen Arbeitsschritten.
Dann kann man sie so ein bisschen zusammendrücken
und hier unten und oben die Rundungen glätten.
Das ist echt wie beim Töpfern!
[Musik]
So kann ich mit der Torte leben.
Also sie ist jetzt schön glatt.
Muss jetzt auch nicht komplett perfekt sein.
Die kommt jetzt so in den Kühlschrank,
darf durchkühlen.
Und dann kommt da nämlich die Fondantdecke drauf.
Und vielleicht kann ich wieder am Strunk weiterarbeiten.
[Musik]
So kann es in der gewünschten Form schön durchtrocknen.
Da ist auch echt ratsam, wenn ihr das macht,
bevor ihr die Torte macht.
Denn ja nach Außentemperatur und Feuchtigkeit
trocknet es mal besser, mal langsamer.
Und wenn ihr das einfach schon vorbereitet habt,
– das kann auch gern zwei, drei Tage vorher schon sein –
dann habt ihr einfach den Strunk schon mal sicher
und
habt nicht den Stress wie ich jetzt,
weil das am gleichen Tag noch durchtrocknen muss.
[Musik]
Wisst ihr was?
Ich beschleunige den Trocknungsvorgang.
Ich trockne zum ersten Mal Fondant
im Dörrautomaten.
Müsste eigentlich gehen.
Ich kann ja die Temperatur ganz präzise niedrig einstellen
und dann müsste es klappen.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Ananas dran.
Ich habe jetzt hier drei Päckchen gelben Fondant.
Und, weil mir der Fondant zu gelb ist,
für die Ananas zumindest,
mische ich hier jetzt noch ein bisschen Weiß rein.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, dass es so ein bisschen pastelliger wird.
Und später wird das dann auch noch schattiert mit Grün,
damit ich einfach noch so einen grünen Farbverlauf habe.
Und die Farben, die lassen sich halt
echt gut mischen untereinander.
[Musik]
Die Farbe gefällt mir sehr gut.
Und jetzt wird diese Decke auch ausgerollt.
Und wenn ihr das nicht ganz gleichmäßig hinbekommt,
könnt ihr zum Beispiel den Ausrollstab nehmen
und entweder Teighölzer benutzen
oder einfach diese Abstandsringe mit 5 oder 3 mm
je nachdem, wie dünn ihr das haben wollt.
Denn dann habt ihr eine schöne gleichmäßig dicke
Rollfondantdecke.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr durch das Kneten so kleine Luftbläschen habt,
könnt ihr die einfach mit einem Messer aufstechen,
ganz vorsichtig die Luft rausstreichen
und noch mal darüberrollen.
Dann sieht man da keine Rückstände mehr.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt die Fondantdecke über die Torte.
Die sprühe ich jetzt kurz mit Backtrennspray ein,
damit die Oberfläche nicht zu trocken ist
und der Fondant eben auch schön haftet.
Jetzt wisst ihr, warum ich eine Zahnbürste habe.
Also hier in der Küche.
Sie ist auch wirklich nur dafür gedacht.
Ich nehme jetzt nämlich die Bäckerstärke noch weg.
Und dann einfach hier darüberlegen.
Und der Fondant der ist auch wirklich schön elastisch.
Der ist mit Sheabutter.
Deswegen reißt er nicht so schnell
oder halt eigentlich fast gar nicht.
Und deswegen könnt ihr den auch
ruhig so ein bisschen ziehen
und jetzt hier mit den Händen flach andrücken.
Die eine Hand nimmt immer die Fondantdecke
und drückt sie weg oder zieht sie weg
und die andere Hand drückt sozusagen
die Luft unten drunter weg.
Und dann schmiegt sich das schön an ohne Falten.
Und gerade bei so Rundungen unten ist es echt schwierig.
Aber es klappt.
Jetzt könnte man noch ein Minion daraus machen.
>> JOSH: Oder Lego.
>> SALLY: Die Reste erst mal grob wegschneiden
mit so einem Marzipan-/Fondantmesser.
Und das könnt ihr auch alles wunderbar aufheben.
Einfach nur luftdicht verpacken
und dann ist es wirklich mehrere Monate haltbar.
Jetzt erst mal die Oberfläche so ein bisschen glätten,
die Rundungen schön ausarbeiten.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich mir hier eine Theke gebaut
beziehungsweise eine Erhöhung.
Und die Ananasform finde ich so jetzt ganz gut.
Ich mache ja diese Kawaii-Form.
Also, wenn ihr eine richtig echte Ananas machen wollt,
muss sie natürlich etwas höher sein
und dafür schlanker,
so wie die Ananas da hinten eben.
Aber das wäre ja langweilig.
Jetzt kommen hier so Rautenmuster rein.
Und die könnt ihr entweder
mit so einem Marzipanmesser zum Beispiel
oder mit Modellierwerkzeug einprägen.
Ich habe jetzt hier tatsächlich in meiner Schublade
so ein Hilfsmittel gefunden mit Rauten dran
und probiere das jetzt aus.
Und wenn es gut ist, dann
nehme ich es in mein Repertoire auf.
Und dann so von links nach rechts einmal durch.
Super!
Das kann man ja auch prima benutzen,
wenn man so Steppleder macht so
oder so ein Kissen
oder Polster für so eine Prinzessinnentorte.
Also ich glaube, Rauten...
Oder
– wie heißt das in Bayern? –
Oktoberfest!
>> JOSH: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Direkt so ein Multitool.
Von der Ananas zum Oktoberfest.
Wer hätte es gedacht?
Josh, hättest du es gedacht?
>> JOSH: Ich bin fasziniert!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und hier unten
fahrt ihr dann einfach mit so einem Modellierwerkzeug
die Linien bis nach unten durch
bis zur Rundung.
Und dann wird es, glaube ich, perfekt.
Also ich finde, den Abschluss kann man hier oben
entweder so lassen
oder einfach noch weiter in die Mitte ziehen,
das heißt, man macht einfach so ein Muster.
Ich probiere es jetzt mal weitestgehend
gleichmäßig.
[Musik]
Es ist so traurig!
Ich mache eine Sommertorte und dann
sieht das Wetter so aus.
Ich habe auch schon im Winter eine Fondanttorte gemacht
und dann war die Sonne irgendwie wieder so heiß,
da waren wieder fast 30°C in meiner Küche.
Ja.
Noch eine zweite Runde oder lasse ich es so?
Eigentlich sieht es so schon recht perfekt aus.
Ich muss sagen, ich lasse es so.
Weil der Strunk kommt ja noch.
Perfekt!
Was ich hier jetzt noch mache,
um das Ganze lebendiger zu machen
– also ich finde es so schon echt ziemlich cool.
Aber, wie gesagt, will ich ja noch
diese grüne Optik reinbringen, die die Ananas hat.
Nicht zu stark, dass sie auch wirklich noch diesen
Kawaii-Charakter hat.
Deswegen nehme ich ein bisschen Pulverfarbe
in Hellgrün,
ein bisschen Dunkelgrün,
ein wenig Orange
und ein wenig Gelb.
Und dann einfach
mit einem trockenen Pinsel in die Farbe rein.
Da muss man sich jetzt so ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Und dann hier einfach diese Linien nachfahren.
Wie gesagt, oben mehr grün
und unten dann eher gelb lassen.
[Musik]
Das ist so,
wo meine BK-Lehrerin meinte:
"Mit der Kunst bringst du es nicht weiter,
nicht weiter als in den Kindergarten."
Und dann komme ich und schattiere.
[Musik]
Guckt schon mal! So sieht jetzt der Ananasstrunk aus
richtig schön getrocknet.
Und jetzt könnt ihr auch hier Pulverfarbe nehmen
und einfach so ein bisschen schattieren.
Ich finde, das macht das Ganze dann
echt so ein bisschen lebendiger und schöner,
weil sich die Pulverfarbe
auch so ein bisschen in die Rillen reinsetzt
und diese Vertiefungen verdunkelt.
[Musik]
Guckt mal.
Also ich finde, das macht schon immer so den Unterschied,
warum dann Torten nicht einfach nur
langweilig aussehen,
sondern so richtig...
Das ist das i-Tüpfelchen
der Tortenkunst!
So. Der kommt kurz zur Seite.
Und dann kann ich meine Blüten auch schattieren
beziehungsweise färben.
Die haben ja jetzt noch gar keine Färbung.
Aber ich muss mir erst die Hände waschen.
Sonst werden sie grün.
Wir essen übrigens hier gerade
die Reste des Bolo Tsunami Kuchens.
Ich hatte noch so viel Bolo Tsunami Soße übrig,
dass wir uns seit fünf Tagen
von nichts anderem mehr ernähren.
Okay, Bolo Tsunami und Gemüse.
Ist halt echt so.
Ein bisschen Verstärkung für den Tag. Wisst ihr?
Oh, wow! Ich nasche im Video.
>> JOSH: Das hast du noch nie gemacht.
>> SALLY: Das habe ich echt noch nie gemacht.
Guckt mal, hier nehme ich so ein bisschen Rosa.
Ich hätte es auch einfach direkt rosa machen können.
Na, egal.
Jetzt habe ich einen schönen Farbverlauf.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr jetzt noch Zuckerperlen reinsetzen
einfach mit essbarem Kleber.
Dann ist die Blume perfekt!
Ui!
Das war viel Kleber.
[Musik]
Und jetzt
habe ich noch was vorbereitet.
Denn meine Ananas bekommt ja noch
– ich fühle mich wie so ein Fernsehkoch.
Meine Ananas bekommt jetzt noch ein Gesicht.
Da ist sie wieder, die Zahnbürste.
Und dafür steche ich jetzt erst mal zwei Augen aus.
Ich nehme jetzt hier so eine Spritztülle ganz einfach,
weil ich jetzt keine runden kleinen Ausstecher habe.
Zeit für einen Löffelchen Bolo!
Josh, tu so, als würden wir arbeiten!
Und jetzt mache ich noch einen kleinen Mund
und nehme die Spritztülle einmal so
und dann
so.
Jetzt ist er traurig.
Aber jetzt ist er glücklich.
Oh, war das süß!
Wow! Wir können die Torte zusammensetzen!
Ich glaube es fast nicht!
Ah! Ich steche jetzt noch...
Ha, oder mache ich es mit Zuckerschrift?
Mh. Ich mache es mit Zuckerschrift.
Ich gucke mal.
Ich probiere es aus.
Denn die Lichtpunkte
muss ich noch machen.
Jetzt geht es ans Zusammensetzen der Torte!
Also hier
der Strunk.
Aber der steht hier oben nicht so gut.
Deswegen
werden ich hier jetzt tatsächlich was ausstechen
und ihn dann da reinsetzen.
Wie sieht es aus?
>> JOSH: Sehr gut!
>> SALLY: So steht er nämlich auch so von ganz alleine.
Süß!
Und bei dem Kawaii-Stil,
also diese süße, niedliche Art des Zeichnens,
ist ganz wichtig, dass das Gesicht süß wird.
Und ein Gesicht sieht immer süß aus,
wenn die Augen ganz groß sind,
wenn die Stirn hoch ist wie bei einem Baby
oder bei süßen Hundewelpen.
Das heißt, die Stirn muss hoch sein,
also hier,
und das Gesicht eher so gedrückt auf dem Part.
So,
so eine Quietsche-,
so ein süßes Knuddelgesicht.
Also werde ich die Augen auch eher weiter unten ansetzen.
Ich muss es jetzt nur kurz zu mir drehen.
Ich habe jetzt hier meinen Kleber in einem Schälchen
und trage es mit einem Pinsel auf.
[Musik]
Und hier steche ich jetzt noch
rosa Pausbäckchen aus und klebe die noch an den Mund.
[Musik]
Mit weißer Zuckerschrift male ich jetzt hier noch
die Lichtpunkte an die Augen.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr noch die Blümchen dransetzen.
Dann ist es ein Mädchen.
Ist sie nicht süß,
die kleine
Piña Colada?
Okay.
Ich würde sagen, ich suche jetzt jemanden,
der die Torte probieren kann.
Und ja, es tut mir schon manchmal weh,
die Torten anzuschneiden,
gerade so, wenn sie so fertiggestellt sind
und ich so absolut keinen Anlass dafür habe.
Wenn ich jetzt jemanden hätte,
der sich über eine Geburtstagstorte gefreut hätte,
wäre es mir tausendmal lieber.
Aber jetzt haben wir keinen Geburtstag.
Egal!
Machen wir halt kurz eine Hawaii-Party hier.
Josh, machen wir eine Hawaii-Party?
>> JOSH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Ja! Wuh!
>> JOSH: Guck mal. Es regnet.
>> SALLY: Es regnet.
Na toll.
[Musik]
Och Mensch!
Wird nichts draus aus unserer Hawaii-Party.
Wenn ich so Hawaii sage, denke ich an
den
Hawaii-Toast.
Das ist der Hawaii-Toast!
Das ist die Piña Colada.
Wolltest du jetzt echt einen Pizzateller?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ein Pizzablech.
>> MURAT: Ich finde, das ist...
Ich habe jetzt gerade keinen Teller,
weil die Spülmaschine läuft.
So. Piña Colada
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> MURAT: erinnert mich natürlich an einen Cocktail.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ein ganz berühmter Cocktail übrigens.
>> SALLY: Sieht schön aus, nicht?
>> MURAT: Und ist Ananas?
Was ist da drin?
Ananas, klar, Piña Colada. Und?
>> SALLY: Und Kokos.
>> MURAT: Und Kokos. Genau.
Piña Colada...
>> SALLY: Oh! Eigentlich hätte ich...
Och Mensch!
Ich hätte so die Ananas und dann noch die
>> SALLY & MURAT: Kokosnuss
>> SALLY: machen muss.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber ohne Witz,
hättest du echt machen müssen.
Ohne Witz.
>> SALLY: Und so eine haarige, weißt du, so...
>> MURAT: Was heißt das jetzt?
So.
>> SALLY: Und?
Ich bin gespannt.
Also, was ich echt sagen muss,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: ich mag Fondanttorten.
Denn der Fondant,
der hält ja praktisch so den ganzen Geschmack,
die ganzen Aromen und auch die Feuchtigkeit in der Torte,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: also wie so ein Schutzmantel.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann trocknet die Torte nicht aus.
Und
es gibt ja so ein Vorurteil,
dass Fondanttorten nicht gut schmecken.
Die schmeckt echt Hammer!
Ohne Witz!
Und zwar, wisst ihr wie die schmeckt?
Kennt ihr
– ich darf jetzt diese Schleichwerbung nicht machen,
aber ich muss es jetzt machen.
>> SALLY: Piña Colada?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Iss mal ganz kurz. Du kommst dann da auch drauf.
An was erinnert dich das?
Kinder Paradiso.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Gell?
Wie Kinder Paradiso schmeckt das.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Boah, Hammer!
>> SALLY: Ich muss sagen,
ich habe ja echt so ein Verhältnis
von Kuchen und Creme gewählt,
eher weniger Creme, mehr Kuchen,
aber man kann die Cremeschicht deutlich noch erhöhen auch.
Also ich finde es so perfekt,
weil es ist nicht mächtig.
Also die
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: ist wie so ein
wie so ein Marmorkuchen mit so ein bisschen Füllung.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wenn ihr das Ganze eher tortiger haben wollt,
>> SALLY: könnt ihr auch gerne noch mehr Creme nehmen.
Aber ich finde es so perfekt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe hier innen drin
so ein Ananas-Curd gemacht.
Weißt du? So statt Lemon Curd.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und das ist auch echt...
Du kannst auch deine Hand benutzen zum Festhalten.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Dann dreht sich das Blech nicht immer weg.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es echt perfekt, also auch
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: die Buttercreme so ganz dünn
und das Ananas-Curd.
Sehr gut!
>> MURAT: Es gibt ja manche Menschen,
die den Fondant nicht essen,
aber hier dazu
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Hammer!
Wirklich!
Weil die Piña Colada, die ist eher so fruchtig, frisch
oder die Ananas
und dann noch die Süße von dem Fondant,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: richtig lecker!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und ich habe auch
das Ananas-Curd nicht zu süß gemacht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und die Buttercreme
habe ich auch zuckerreduziert.
Also ich finde auch,
man kann den Fondant auf jeden Fall mitessen,
ob Fondant oder fondant.
>> MURAT: Ist die Ananas-Curd
genau so gemacht wie die Lemon Curd?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Boah!
Bitte das als Brotaufstrich alleine schon!
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich hole es dir kurz.
>> MURAT: Allein schon das als Brotaufstrich!
Das Lemon Curd,
das haben wir häufig als Brotaufstrich gemacht.
Aber dieses Ananas-Curd
will ich mal ganz kurz probieren.
>> SALLY: Das habe ich auch so noch nirgends gesehen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Das könntest du mal als Rezept selber machen.
Oder hast du das alles hier drin gehabt.
>> SALLY: Ich habe es als Rezept selber gemacht
im Video.
>> MURAT: Also es hat ja mehrere Rezepte
und dieses Ananas-Curd, das ist bis jetzt richtig lecker.
>> SALLY: Warte, ich bringe es dir.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott!
Du bist dir auch für nichts zu schade, gell?
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Wie süß ist das bitte?!
>> MURAT: Das ist ja mal cool!
>> SALLY: Komm!
Und vor allem, wenn du in den Kühlschrank guckst
und dann guckt dich so ein lachendes Glas an!
>> MURAT: Das ist bestimmt voll lustig,
wenn ihr ein Hotel habt.
Wir haben übrigens voll viele Zuschauer, die ein Hotel haben.
>> SALLY: Ich habe so viele Freunde, die ein Hotel haben!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Nicht.
>> MURAT: Genau, das als am Tisch so richtig.
>> SALLY: Ist süß, oder?
>> MURAT: Voll süß. Ja.
Boah!
Darf ich ganz kurz?
>> SALLY: Hier.
>> MURAT: Boah, ich liebe ja Lemon Curd über alles!
>> SALLY: Haben wir so ein Bild gemacht, Samira?
Mit dem Deckel mit der Ananas drauf?
Ja!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mega, nicht?
Und so ist auch die Konsistenz jetzt auch abgekühlt.
>> MURAT: Boah! Da hast du aber auch gar keinen...
Hast du da überhaupt Zucker reingemacht?
>> SALLY: Nee, ganz wenig.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich?
>> SALLY: Hm. Weil ich wusste,
für die Torte muss es so erdig sein.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Jetzt mal ungelogen, das könnte auch ein Joghurt sein.
Weißt du das?
>> SALLY: Das könnte auch...
Gehe jetzt nicht mit deinem Löffel noch mal rein!
>> MURAT: Ach so. Tut mir leid.
Oh! Ich esse das jetzt einfach noch.
Tut mir leid.
Och, so ein Pech aber auch!
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was das auch sein könnte?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, geschmacklich erinnert es an Apfelmus.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Da ist jetzt echt kein Zucker drin?
Nur ganz wenig?
>> SALLY: Wenig.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Echt wenig.
Also Murat feiert
das Ananas-Curd.
Er feiert auch die Torte, hoffe ich doch.
>> MURAT: Boah, ist das cool!
>> SALLY: Feierst du auch meine Torte?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Hammer!
Ich feiere alles.
>> SALLY: Ist die Torte stabil?
>> MURAT: Ich feiere.
Du bist stabil.
Deutschland ist stabil.
>> SALLY: Piña Colada ist stabil, Junge!
>> MURAT: Piña Colada, ich feiere die.
>> SALLY: Also macht die Torte doch gerne nach!
Ich glaube wirklich,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: dass viele sich über diese Torte
als Geburtstagsgeschenk freuen würden.
>> MURAT: Boah, ist das cool!
>> SALLY: Übrigens backt für mich
nie jemand eine Geburtstagstorte.
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> SALLY: Weiß nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich backe dir mal eine.
>> SALLY: Danke.
Das war ein Seitenwink.
Yay!
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Schreibt mir gerne, welche Torte ihr als Nächstes sehen wollt.
Vielleicht tatsächlich eine Lego-Torte
oder eine Minions-Torte?
Wir haben vorhin
– weißt du, da war das so gelb.
Und dann haben wir gedacht,
das sieht aus wie Lego und Minions.
Ich habe gleich an Minions gedacht,
Josh an Lego
und Samira auch an Lego.
Die kam auch rein.
Ja.
Also Tortenwünsche gerne in die Kommentare.
Viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> MURAT: Die ist echt der Hammer!
Die schmeckt wie
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Paradiso, Kinder Paradiso.
>> SALLY: Ja, wegen der Buttercreme einfach
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und
dieses Locker-Leichte.
>> MURAT: Okay, Creme könnt ihr noch
ein bisschen mehr machen.
Also Tschüss!
Macht es gut!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ich schreibe es ins Rezept rein,
weil ich habe auch noch Creme übrig.
Ich schreibe rein: 5mm Creme.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Tschüss.
Hammer, hey!
>> SALLY: Komm.
>> MURAT: Ich musste diesmal gar nicht lügen.
Es hat wirklich geschmeckt.
>> SALLY: Komm, Piña, du kommst wieder
in meinen Kühlschrank!
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mh.
[Musik]